i had sometimes friends over
entrepreneurs and just because of them
lumos got successful why because they
just said like andre
this is a blind spot you shouldn't go
that way because of these things i'm
like
damn if i hadn't talked to you i would
have worked on this kind of
small problem for like the next three
[Music]
months
andre sephon judge thank you so much for
joining me how are you today
good good i'm in bavaria right now in
germany
with my parents and my siblings and i'm
just like enjoying my time with them and
yeah how are you man
i i'm doing fantastic thank you very
much you know the last time we spoke it
was a
about i guess you know six seven months
ago we were
both in california and so definitely
times have changed
but i i i would love to talk about your
journey before we talk about this
journey we have to say you're working on
a startup in stealth mode right now
uh lumos uh you've completed a seed
round recently with andreessen horowitz
as backers which is fantastic and i
can't wait to do a follow-up episode
when you come out of stealth mode uh
hopefully you know
still when we're when we have this show
going but but i'm very very excited for
now to talk about
your journey to talk about your
upbringing in germany selling a company
to the government which is
very an unlikely situation harvard
stanford
you name it andre take it away how do
you get started
um so one principle one principle that i
have
is so we as human beings are very lost
adverse right
so as a human being we don't want to
lose
we want to like losing is more dangerous
than winning
right yeah and that's why everything
that i do
i i have a mental model to put 20
percent more risk
on my decisions right i have a motor
called screw it just do it
like like richard branson um and i think
that's internet with a lot of luck and a
lot of failures and a lot of screw it
just do it you just like
opportunities open up and then hopefully
grab them and then you don't even need
to be smart i'm not smart you
um just have to be sometimes a little
bold and silly
i love that so i'd love for you to tell
me a little bit more about your
upbringing and how you go
through your crazy adventures while
keeping the the screwa just do it
mentality within it
yeah so um i was born and raised in
germany um in bavaria in a small village
here uh four siblings i'm the oldest
brother for siblings my parents came to
germany shortly before the war started
in croatia
and um yeah did my did my high school
here
here then i went for undergrad um to
to tu munich it's a technical university
and i really fell in love with
social businesses like with the tech
tech for public good
so i started to a tech company in uganda
first
wow um it was about like kind of
fighting youth unemployment with
innovative
um at um at technologies and it's still
out there my co-founders are still doing
that
and so that's how i got really
interested um to
go to the east coast um because at
harvard and mit the amazing researchers
um in the space and so
then i went uh for a year for my final
year my senior year i went to harvard
and did a lot of kind of um yeah things
there i did computer science
and then i took a class at hks called
digital government it's taught by david
e
and so many cool cios from different
governments from great britain
from the states um from new york came to
the class and told us
the students hey this is how tech for
public good works
this is how governments can be reshaped
government
is the biggest entity the biggest
company on this planet
right um just the german government for
example makes
a hundred times as more more revenues
than uber in a year which is which is
insane right
yeah it's insane it's insane and so and
so i was just like so
like i was always trying to like how can
i maximize my potential and tech for the
public good
so i look into germany and i saw like
that not much things are going on there
and the the cheryl sandberg of the
german government the chief of staff
of germany he got elected in 20 2018
nim was really into digital
transformation so just like emailed him
somehow i found somehow his email and
emailed him saying like
what do you think if i bring the 10 best
computer scientists
to the government and we work with you
and you don't um you know outsource to
accenture or ibm
and i'm not sure why he did that but his
advisor called me and said my boss told
me that
you have an idea what's the idea and so
we got a little bit of funding
um and built that kind of a sort of a
fellowship
um at the beginning where 10 people in
the first year and then the next year
was 35 almost
people came to the government and worked
with different ministries
on very high level um tech programs
and um yeah that's um that was like how
tech for germany started and then after
two years the government bought us
um so that we become a tech task force
within the government because you know
outsourcing is always hard
so government said let's buy you let's
let's be internal and then we don't need
to outsource
then we can grow this from within um
and yeah that's that's the story in a
nutshell how
i try to maximize it for the public good
and andre i have to go back a little bit
to creating those organizations in
uganda at
tech uh doing good helping with fighting
youth unemployment
because it's a little irregular for a
young entrepreneur to come and say
i want to do first of all i want to
leverage
technology and entrepreneurial passion
to do
good especially at a young age before
going and you know trying to build you
know a billion dollar company
and and then doing it in uganda
going outside of europe outside your
your country and going there
what was the thought process there what
actually what was the motivation to go
and do all that
it's actually it's again actually very
simple and it goes back to the screw
just do it just like
let's go um i read a book called poor
economics
by two mit professors and they actually
won the the
nobel nobel prize i think two years ago
and i read it like i think 10 years ago
and it really resonated with me they
said like how non-profit
nonprofits sometimes don't work like big
ngos don't work and they say like what
what sorts of non-profits are the most
high leverage
right and i was so like wow this is
amazing i was like come on let's let's
let's try it myself and then i had a
friend in uganda
for some reason um and he had a
connection
to ugandan high school and then we just
like came up with the concept of
building
school enterprises which means we need
we wanted to teach
students how to be entrepreneurs
themselves and so we built
businesses within schools where they
kind of learned how to do all those
business stuff sold things
earned money for themselves you know to
have for school tuition
and basically then i flew over with two
three other friends
um again because of the book because i
had a connection there
and because you know let's let's do it
i just i just love that so in any
transition uh
you you took that those classes you took
that final year at harvard you also
spent them time at stanford also
stanford and gsb where we met
walk me through some of those those
experiences very few people get to
experience you know both the technical
university in germany
and harvard then stanford for a master's
and then stanford for mba
how do you live through those
experiences yeah every every school is a
little different right
for example munich is you just have
final exams
in germany so you don't have homework
you don't have essays and all that kind
of stuff
so basically the final exams are really
hard
but you have a lot of time to explore
your interests in like
through internships or through
entrepreneurship so team munich really
taught me
to like leverage my free time and do
something
something like hopefully hopefully
valuable so that was kind of team unique
uh i went to harvard uh because a friend
again a friend i met a friend
from munich and he said like i went to
harvard and said like that's not
possible and i said like he said
yes apply for a scholarship i was like
damn let's just like apply whatever
so i applied i got lucky i always say i
have a shitty last name you saw you it
was
hard to pronounce it so they said like
we practiced quite a lot
yes yeah and then howard said we need
diversity with that we need people with
shitty last names and so
so um thank you dad thank you dad for
having a shitty last name so
that howard howard was interesting and
it was very arty
very traditional i need to say more
traditional and team unique and stanford
um many people will go like that the
normal routes of let's say
consulting banking and all that kind of
stuff which is very important
um but i learned more to be like i i
explore philosophy there i explore kind
of you know government and all that kind
of stuff
which brought me back to berlin harvard
brought me back to berlin
for exploring government because it was
more traditional
and stanford is insane like i'm stanford
is more my vibe
like you come there we started this
company i didn't want to start a company
i was just like i want to relax a little
bit after tech for germany
but then a friend and i started hacking
in march
and then suddenly one friend says like
hey i'm gonna connect you to the
we do something with emails so he said
like i'm gonna connect you to a vp of
gmail and this i'm like damn crazy and
like hey here
is a little bit of funding hey here's y
combinator and
um and long story short it's not that
we are the smartest people it's not that
we are the best people just like the
ecosystem that just like
those are giants and they carry you on
their shoulders and that's why you have
so much support
to do something valuable so that's in
terms of um stanford is just like it
it was the most entrepreneurial school
and so those
i have to say one of the things that
that i keep
hearing you come back to come back and
allude to is this a network and
community that you've built around you
that has inspired you to do these things
whether it's the experience back in
africa
or then you know your friend going to
harvard or when you're at stanford and
getting exposed to all these wonderful
people
and and i have to say that i completely
agree with you i think that you know
surrounding yourself with the best
people people that will motivate you and
will carry you
when you need to be carried and you will
carry them when they need to be carried
is one of the most important elements
here
talk to me a little bit about why you
why you're even an entrepreneur
because you know already at such energy
you have you've had you've had so many
different initiatives that you've gone
through
so many successful ones i mean real real
successful ones successful ones
at the degree that people sometimes work
their whole life to get to and you bring
this level of passion and excitement
and that that really goes through this
video so please share with me a little
bit about
about why you're even an entrepreneur
yeah that's a that's a fantastic
question
and i i've really heard this question
why so i think
i think i have an equation for myself
and i want to maximize three things in
life number one the number of people i
touch
times the quality i make in those
people's lives so which means like
improving
page load by 0.02 for a billion people
is nice but it needs to be both right
and then the third
part is feeling in peace with myself
meaning
working with friends not with colleagues
having autonomy and waking every day and
laughing
you know and fooling around and i just
found so far that like through startups
i can maximize this equation in the best
way
i'm not saying that this is the only way
i i just mean like for me with my kind
of
characteristics and with my kind of pre
i
am for example sometimes too
unprofessional i would say to work in
bigger companies which is actually it's
it sounds funny but it's actually true
um so
that's why with my flaws and weaknesses
and my strengths i think
entrepreneurship is kind of the best way
to
um fulfill this equation that i have for
myself
and what does it distill for you so
obviously the screw just do it
is a huge part of of for you to be an
entrepreneur what what are some what are
some other pieces that in the background
understand okay this is
this is what i constituted as being
entrepreneurial in my domain
yeah so i would say being
entrepreneurial
to me means like really caring about a
problem
so i don't think an entrepreneur is
someone that has an idea like
i often hear people asking me like what
do you think of this idea
i was just like what's what's the
problem first so entrepreneurs don't be
people don't need to be people that kind
of start companies entrepreneurs can be
people and kind of big non-profits can
be
people and also big corporations that's
kind of find a new problem that hasn't
been solved before
and find a unique and innovative
solution to to solve this problem it's
very broad
but i think that's that's how um i would
define
what a entrepreneur is right and
so if you're looking across the spectrum
now you know you have
college students or you know young
people in general all over the world
that are doing all sorts of things many
of them
you know outside of the united states
might look at a place like stanford and
harvard and say no this is this place is
not for me like this is
like you know another planet there's no
way i'll get there some people
even you know within stanford and within
the united states they're saying okay
start up no way i'll never have access
to these people and these opportunities
what what are some what are some of your
insights for those people because one of
the goals for the show is also
to expose these really non-linear
journeys
and it you know what i've been observing
for over 300 guests is that
most commonly people didn't expect to
reach the successes they've had but it
was
through taking risk and being
adventurous and entrepreneurial that
they actually found themselves in a
position where they could enjoy it
yeah that's that's that's also a
fantastic question i'd be curious
actually to hear from you answer as well
on that but
what i think is we until we're 30
we don't i mean i'm really privileged to
say this so that's kind of one thing
like i'm privileged
to say all those things that i can say
because like once you are at harvard or
at stanford or team munich you have a
certain safety net
so i know that i cannot fall deeper than
that because i'm if you're in computer
science you'll always find a job
somewhere right so you won't you want
and you'll always be able to kind of a
little bit support your family so that's
kind of a
i just want to say that at the beginning
um once you have the safety net so once
you reach a certain safety net for
yourself and you need to define the
safety nets for yourself i have a very
low bar for safenet some people have a
higher bar
but once you reach that i think in your
20s you don't have a lot to lose
right i mean with third you can still
become a director at google or direct or
facebook or
whatsoever a partner at a consultancy
and and work towards that but i think
until you're 30 i mean why not just
trying out like one thing or two things
you have just like a few shots and
many people say you have a lot of shots
in life i you actually don't
you know you have to kind of commit to
something for at least two or three
years
and right why not taking those risks
early on
and once you reached a certain safety
net because as said
um opportunity kind of comes up for
those people that kind of just like
tried
and tried it they're kind of not the
common way and that's kind of that's a
kind of a broad advice
um but that's that's how i've been
thinking about life so far
i i have to say that i couldn't agree
more i think that you know
while while our lives are very
non-linear we're
oftentimes at a point in time where we
where the circumstances that we have now
are much more convenient to take those
risks and and a deep failure
in one circumstance is not equal to a
deep failure in another circumstance
you know the classic example once you
have kids and a family to support
it's a whole different ballgame right
you can just say okay i'm working on
this fun startup and then quitting
but definitely when you're young you can
go to uganda you can try all these
different things especially things that
you know that are moonshot
and have little chance to succeed and
you know in
in your situation uh you actually did
manage to make them succeed which is
obviously the rare occurrence the nature
of startups is to fail
but i think that but that's very
inspiring and i have this that taking
from this conversation
screw it just do it for me that's a i'm
gonna adopt that
that mindset for me too andre i know
that we can't speak too much about lumos
and what you guys are actually doing but
what we
what i do want to ask you a little bit
is about your experience now
as a as a founder early stage co-founder
in silicon valley with raising funds
from some of the top
vcs in the world walk me through some of
the things that either surprised you
or challenged you in this experience
because you've had you've
founded initiatives before what's been
different this time around
what surprised me is number one how you
really need to hone in and create a
network for yourself
um and you know coming from a small
village in bavaria i was never kind of i
never knew how big this importance is
but let's let's say for example for vcs
um if you send cold emails to vcs i
realize no one will reply
people will say like yeah nice they will
reply but just like the power dynamics
are so much different
so one thing that i learned is just like
asking random people to say like hey do
you know
vc can you introduce me done and this
changed
the game like just like one introduction
change changed the whole game that's
kind of the first thing second thing
what
really surprised me is how much more
philosophy there is in the valley which
i which means like i had sometimes
friends over
entrepreneurs and just because of them
lumos got successful
why because they just said like andre
this is a blind spot you shouldn't go
that way because of these things i'm
like
damn if i hadn't talked to you i would
have worked on this kind of
small problem for like the next three
months so
to summarize that's kind of two small
things like kind of creating the network
of like getting introduced to people
which
was so important that's kind of the
first thing and the second thing is
um getting this kind of your own
advisory board
you're having your own advisory board of
entrepreneurs and people that you
respect and that kind of push you
and the last thing i also want to say is
in germany recruiting was
way easier damn it's so hard in the
valley
i'm like oh shoot i really
underestimated that
um it's it's really really really really
hard
well so if this can be of any help if
anybody's interested in being
a part of this of this incredible
company and
please reach out to andre it really is
incredible i i
have i got a chance to know a little bit
about what you're doing and i think it's
just fascinating
and but andre i want to touch on on the
point that he said about building your
own advisory board because i think it's
really understated
in a lot of situations and i think that
you said it beautifully
this whole notion of when you're working
on something you know some people like
to keep it a secret
uh you know i'm not saying go and
broadcast with the world you know
all the ins and outs of your
intellectual property but building this
this group of people that you really
trust that you
really believe in not just that they'll
keep your secret but really believe in
their opinion
and being very transparent with them
sharing with them having them
be part of the journey as a family of
the of the company
and even those you know a dinner side
conversations
which could potentially you know save
you three months they could save you a
round of fine
funding they could possibly save you
from from losing your biggest client
and i've heard this so many times and
that's maybe a push for your listeners
um one thing that people underestimate
is like people
responding like um yeah what i try to
kind of
really kind of um i trained the muscle
at harvard for uh for example just
reaching out to random people you need
to have something
right you kind of say like hey tell me
about your life story well i mean you
can because your
podcast because that's also something
but i mean like if for example
in um what i was really curious about is
um algorithmic vc when i was at harvard
so i reached out to many many vcs just i
was curious i read papers at mit about
like
how data science can influence vce and
many people replied and i
built like a small advisory board around
that and then also the government
i reached out to 20 people just one
person replied but this one person
again that the success rate wasn't high
but this one person changed my life
um so what what pushes me think about
what you're truly passionate about think
about like
become a little bit of an expert in
there and find those people just like
get advice on something
um that that you're that you're truly
passionate about and then
um build a relationship because it
really works
i love it no no i i definitely love it
thank you so so much for
spending the time here talking to me i
know how busy you are
and you've been very very generous with
your time andre thank you and i look
forward to doing a follow-up episode in
september
so that we can get to know lumos a
little bit more and i can't wait to hear
more about your journey
but before we leave i have to ask you
for the most important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
four words screw it just do it
screw it just do it i'll take it andre
thank you very very much this is
wonderful
and stay safe and stay healthy peace man
thanks man
you